'The national debt crosses the $20 trillion mark.'
It was big news when our national debt recently passed the $20 trillion mark.
What’s less understood is exactly why having such a massive debt is a bad thing.
The sheer size of the existing debt is deeply worrying to economists on both the left and the right,
who agree that when debt reaches 90 percent of GDP
it means painfully slow growth, creating what’s called a “debt overhang.”
A group of progressive economists affiliated with the University of Massachusetts
predicted in 2013 that a debt burden at that level
would result in an annual growth rate of just 2.2 percent,
which means economic stagnation and anemic job growth.
So when will our debt load cross the 90 percent threshold?
It’s actually been at more than 100 percent of GDP for years now.
Periods of slow growth associated with debt overhangs almost always last more than a decade
and sometimes stretch out over  a quarter century.
That means that in 25 years, the overall economy will be about 75 percent the size it would have been
if the government had only gotten the debt in check.
Countries like New Zealand, Canada, and Germany have demonstrated
that when governments reduce debt good things happen.
U.S. spending, by contrast, has been above 20 percent of GDP for years,
which is well above the historical average.
No wonder the Congressional Budget Office predicts
that the economy will grow less than 2 percent annually over the next decade.
Compare that to growth rates of more than 3 percent for much of the post-World War II period.
Barack Obama, and George W. Bush
were leaders who lacked the integrity to do what’s best for the country
by keeping spending and debt in line.
President Donald Trump also shows no interest
in explaining to the public how runaway debt chokes off the future.
That’s a failure which we’ll all be paying for for a very long time to come.
'I am the king of debt, I do love debt.'